tell you what I'm doing what I'm going
to give you one more day we'll stay
around Birmingham and you've got to pay
if you don't pay you're gonna summon the
consequences and I'm all about bad
consequences yeah
this Geezer mate was found now to the
floor nailed to the floor right now for
me now through his hands didn't do
nothing else didn't do his legs don't
his friends and of course he pays the
money mate
from the ig5 I was sexually abused a
child
um
by my uncle and so please record and he
got Nick he got seven years but after
that
um I was in my school and I was just
going crazy fighting all the time 24 7
and it just ruined my life it just
ruined my life this is why I'm in and
out of prison I've been in that prison
in my life and this is why I'm a violent
person because of that mine ain't
similar I won't interfered with or
anything else like that but I dealt with
another problem right
my problem was I come up in an age where
no Irish and no dogs were like the guy
in the boarding houses there was a
racial abuses everywhere okay I didn't
want to go to school I bunked up school
all the time went shoplifting my mum and
dad didn't know what I was up to and so
mixing with the wrong people
finished up getting approved School
some Vincent's in Dartford Kent but
they're three years there came out of
there I weren't out all that long I
finished up getting the Detention Center
and crashed a roadblock police roadblock
and and around
Chris but it's about 17.
then I got Boston
holiday Bay
I was fighting all the time I was always
getting backed up in Boston mate
I mean
I know that violence prevails it it was
something I could use
either power
a power that I could stand up for myself
and I weren't frightened good and so
from now onwards I got in all kind of
fights and I got myself involved with
this and once you start they know you
you can fight people come you know they
don't want you on their thumb they want
you with them is that what age was when
you started fighting Christmas I was
talking about I was maybe 10 10 years
ago and I remember one time I came out
of school and we we'd done this
gardening project on the bomb site and a
kid called Andrews came over he said who
do you think you are and he threw a
rhino at me so him and I had a fight and
we must have been
throwing right hand is that right left
and center and uh it must have gone on
for about 500 yards and we finished up
outside of a green Grocers shop
and uh he went on the floor and the
green grocer came out give me half a
crown okay and I thought I said what's
that for he said that's one of the best
fights I've seen so you know that was it
from then onwards I mean I knew Violet's
paid
I worked with uh I worked with Jimmy for
some time who was Jimmy can you explain
that to me yeah Jimmy Tibbett was uh he
was good good fighter in his in his time
yeah
um he looked after me he was my trainer
he was a trainer um he was against a
proper gangster Mike I mean everyone was
fighting him around South is London
South London he could knock anybody out
yeah but he taught me to fight one day
Eddie Eddie always has to pick some
money out for him and he asked us to
pick some money up and I said all right
me and Jim went down and see his people
and uh one of the guys was a bit funny
about playing over the money right this
is really the first time it got a bit
violent you know I mean so Jimmy went to
see the guy and the guy was only knowing
you know I think it was about 60 Grand
you know because I mean a lot of money
yeah that's what he was playing with so
he says Jimmy look I haven't got the
money yet but what I'll do I will pay
you bet bits and pieces so Jimmy said no
no listen this is why it's gone too long
you've got to pay it now so the guy said
I got it you're going to get it you have
to wait so Jim citizen there's
consequences of this yeah bad
consequences yeah well it always is yeah
so he said what do you mean he says bad
consequence if you don't pay this money
today right I'll tell you what I'm gonna
do I'm going to go away now for a couple
of hours we'll take my mate with me
we're gonna go away I'm gonna come back
and then the consequences you're going
to see where the consequence comes up so
Jimmy Tibbett used to always carry
um Rose cut as women you know those guys
cutting loads off you know the stems
yeah he took his arm and I was going
boom took his chopped his little finger
off with the rose Cutters he said that's
the first starting thing that's the
first consequences right you see if I
come back here and you ain't got my
money he said the next one's gonna go
down down and down again on the door
your [ __ ] hand he played it mate yeah
is there anything that's stuck in your
mind what was the you would say the
worst thing you've done yeah I used to
work for a big big big company yeah big
company
um
big company yeah and my job was I was an
enforter I always go down
I've done quite a few in London the same
bit I always go down to maybe
Birmingham a lot because Birmingham was
dealing with uh yeah my town the metal
that was dealing in Copper yeah car
businesses gold silver diamonds when I
went there and I'd give it to the guy I
said what you've got 10 days they give
me 14 days I'm giving you 10 days they
don't know he doesn't know they give me
14 days yeah
so you've got 10 days to pay it right
so after the ten thousand goes down and
said look you know is it something sweet
and money money for me I know we ain't
got the money I said what is that then
so we've got a few important problem let
me show you what it is you [ __ ] took
that box off of me you know I'll give
you 10 days so go uh no I'm probably I'm
telling you what I'm doing right I'm
gonna give you one more day we'll stay
around Birmingham and you've got a pipe
if you don't pay you're gonna summon the
[ __ ] consequences and I'm all about
bad consequences yet
this Geezer mate was found now to the
[ __ ] floor nailed to the floor right
now for me [ __ ] now through his hands
didn't do nothing else then do his legs
found his [ __ ] ass and of course he
paid the money mate that's what I did
yeah you know I didn't give a [ __ ] about
what this that and the other sorry
swearing but I didn't care Chris yeah I
didn't care what I did because that was
my job and in force her and I was and I
was good what I don't Chris yeah do you
know what I mean yeah and I learned from
Jimmy Tibbett I learned from him
worst thing I've ever done
and I was going out with a girl
and uh
Sheena I had another girlfriend
I've got around the house
and a guy comes out
he's got a knife in his hand
and he said to me um
don't come back here he said because
this is waiting for you
I said I'm not arguing with you about
your girlfriend
Let's uh let's leave it there
anyway a bit of chat went on
but I went on a bit of business that
takes care of somebody in Brighton
when I got back my wife yeah good place
come back to London
my wife said somebody had come with a
door
three guys
one had a scar down his boat race and uh
they were you know looking for me
it's the same guy pulled a knife out
half a while I'm gonna have this I went
to my Brother Jimmy's and got a shooter
went down because it was over 38
definitely
I went down I went to this place
I got out of the car be about eight
o'clock at night
and he came out of the house with a
knife in his hand and his mates around
him
fired one into him
I thought a couple at the other people
I fired another one in the Wind
he went down on the floor I've gone
right up to him and I put out the case
to his head which one pull it I tried to
put it back I've run out of bullets
anyway I got in a car buggered off got
my wife and we moved up a little bit how
did you feel with that power in power
here
when you had that thing how did you feel
all I was thinking about was someone
grass in me yeah I like to get away
but I'll tell you what happened in one
of my sentences yeah one of my sentences
are a big sentence here say like I'll be
20 odd years what did you get it why did
you get in what was the what was it all
my all my runs all my gbaits attempted
murder police officers let me sort of
thing it's always violence against
police officers and well I'm obvious
yeah
it's always a good prison but I met a
lot of people in there there was one guy
in there called tank it doesn't really
matter really but
tank and he played a lot of basketball
big black guy massive yeah
and one day we've been called up to the
up late we don't do the operate we're in
the kitchen yeah but one day they called
us up because it was a bit of trouble we
go to the up plate we've got to serve
out the food but it's late you know
anyway he comes in his tank late so
we've got loads of eggs left over bacon
tomatoes and all this sort of thing
there
so what's it saying oh mate is what you
want whatever we want right so there's
five eggs there so I'll give him two
eggs there's only three except for us
egg each last mate yeah so I turn around
he's got my [ __ ] eggs he's done the
eggs prison is about food Chris you know
it's right oh yeah so so what are you
doing put the eggs back you wouldn't
know I was thinking that [ __ ] toilet
so as I put my tray down outside of all
this my food's on it he went to kick me
in the face screws are there but they
let it go Chris I'll go in the toilet
room I mean I want to fight this Geezer
but on a boxing right I'm going to try
and bang bang peeing him and he's
[ __ ] come behind me jump me push me
down the stairs and three of them have
got hold of me and my tummy's been
ripped open he's done with the standing
like the over down and whipped my tummy
up and stand here about three big cuts
so I mean there's only more power I was
nearly 1920 Stone powerlifting massive
because it's only that that got me out
of it I've got them off here and I
banged up and I put this thing around I
was in the kitchen anyway forget about
all that but what happened I knew that
one of us is going to die
one of us is going to kill each other
without a show without you
so for the best thing I can do here is
do this [ __ ] Jesus before he does
meet you
that is square wood with an angle on it
to stop the door running around you
so he's gone through to the still one
hour what up across the [ __ ]
exclusion here I don't give a [ __ ] I'm
not gonna I ain't gonna let him kill me
Christianity mind the opportunity I've
got Chris because I'm gonna get killed
yeah I'll hit him with his thing and I
split his hair open and I've run
now the screws are playing the whole
[ __ ] Wing up yeah
now I know I'm [ __ ] gonna get killed
yeah all right so
I'm in there for about what half an hour
I can heal outside all the rambling
gambling I'm just gonna go on here mate
and they come in for the door and they
drop me Chris with a [ __ ] Dart a
dummy question I was on the floor I'm
aware but I can't [ __ ] move Chris all
my muscles are gone yeah
and they I can't come in and they'd
smashed me to pieces and they dummy in
the neck yeah one and then Barker next
thing I know I know it's Parker I say
hey ain't I can't feel because Camp it
was a sea cat yeah that's right yeah so
he took me to focus and they said what
this what exist time can be dealt with
by the police outside
or by the prison authorities what we're
going to do we're going to essentially
ourselves Mr Steel
and it sends me what's an atmosphere
you're going to go
to a segregation unit in every prison in
this [ __ ] country more or less what
he said yeah yeah and you'll be there no
more
than one day or no less than one day no
more than 28 days right in the end I
wound up in shops of prison yeah well
the best thing I went to believe it or
not was Dartmoor in the block yeah and
they looked off me don't know because I
was saying I was on a [ __ ] die Chris
the same thing asked Craig what was your
longest sentence what was it for and can
you tell me a little bit about what was
the prison like
was
pretty much make the murder yeah murder
yeah and um
first of all I mean he wasn't guilt with
no Christmas no no I mean what it was it
wasn't a plan murder or anything else I
mean people say oh he was taken down
there to diet that was rubbish where's
the tape in the house didn't it it was a
blonde Carol's house yeah yeah and we've
gone down there and we go in thinking
there's genuine the party but when we go
in
maybe it comes running in the room
where's the girls with the booze and all
the rest of it did he come and forever
ever got into Christ he never come to a
party yeah and when we go down there's
two kids who've never ever met the craze
before The Mills Brothers there's Tony
and me and macv I can't get my my in my
car outside the Regency because I'm
blocked in
anyway we go over there and we go
downstairs we've seen the twins earlier
on that night it was their mother's
birthday and it was a nice evening what
have you and we've gone down in anyway
Ronnie starts out the Reggie as a around
with macv
the next thing I know
is Reggie pulls a shooter out
I said I'll never come down here for
this and I go and walk out
and Ronnie Craig comes out he's just a
Connie Wyatt what's the matter with
Chris
he said he didn't come down
for this anyway he said to Connie take
him on because I ate quite a few drinks
they dropped me off home I don't know
what's gone on after that
and I'm sitting over my dad and uh I'm
having a cup of coffee and I think I
better go and get my car because I'll
need it tomorrow
anyway I'll get a cab and go up to reach
about one o'clock in the morning
and uh
get my car and I'll go around Legend
Chris you know yeah you're a legend you
know yeah
I'll go around to every road yeah knock
on the door and Ronnie Bender I'm sure
I said it's Tony there he said no he
said he's he's gone I'll see what Ronnie
see you later mate I went to walk away
so Chris don't need me
I said what do you mean I've only been
this is that yeah he said they've killed
him I said well killed him
he said they've killed uh maybe I went
no no not in front of all them people
you know you don't do things exactly
exactly you keep it quiet
so what happened was
he said Chrissy said help me I said
where are they he said they've run away
and I went what he said yeah he said
they're gone so I said who's with you he
said nobody
what's your instructions
I've got to take him and Fry him over a
Railway Bridge so I try and all Mash him
up I don't know and you know there's no
evidence of murder or anything else on
that
I'll go downstairs and there's a body
there
and I'm thinking one of the guys been
knocked out he's going to wake up any
minute
he's dead stab him to death yeah well
Reggie did yeah
but it was rummy heart their cousin
funny art yeah I know I went and got the
got the knife out of the kitchen and put
it in Reggie's hand I thought it was
Ronnie Bender no it was one of the arms
did that me so Ronnie Hart when he did
that oh well really Bender
okay but Ronnie Hart put on other people
okay so anyway
Ronnie Bender's down there around there
so I said well come with me well I went
in the kitchen and I found some socks I
said put them socks on your hands as you
do you know yeah
I put socks on mine
I went upstairs there was a bedroom
there I walked in the bedroom
and I've taken an idea down off
but I've looked over in the corner and
there's two young babies fast asleep no
no they the Twins were supposed to be
looking after the kids what had the
party down there
anyway we go downstairs
we get mate with his body on a on a
what's her name on the blanket probably
either down I got in it and you got in
there no no no
I'm eating cookies
what happened then was
um
gone downstairs
me and Ronnie have got the bike got
McPhee up in the hallway my brother Tony
comes looking for me
knocks on the door he comes in he gets
involved you understand what I'm saying
so I said look I've got a car I'm in the
follow-up
and I'll I'll follow the Tony said I'll
do that
anyway I've always protected Tony that's
been big brothers yeah yeah yeah for
sure anyway I like Tony you know yeah it
was good it was a sweet man it was good
man and uh anyway across the road it's a
bagel shop yeah where they're going in
and getting bagels and cat drawings yeah
stuff like that so we've got to get a
window where nobody's there
so we get that window we get Mac that he
try and get him in the boot of the car
you can't get a big man in the boot of
the car so put him in the back seat Tony
jumps in the driving seat we follow up
near Ronnie Bender with tyranny I've got
a shooter down by the side of me
as we're driving along a police car
Falls in behind
my brother's car or make vintage car
which my brother's driving no way am I
going to let them stop standards you
know and and pull him in he's got a body
in the back exactly exactly and they
just stand on yeah well I can't let that
happen yeah for sure anyway
I'm following the car and I'm thinking
please don't stop if you stop someone's
going to get hurt thank God the police
car turned off yeah now if there's a if
there's a tragedy if there's a comedy at
the same time is it the same tragedy of
everything so now policemen could have
been been hurt
Ronnie Ben has pulled into it because
Ronnie bend the knees out I'm pulled
into it Tony's pulled into it we go down
we go through the Blackwood tunnel
thinking that we put it over the other
side of the water
and it'll take it off the East End
you followed my line of thinking last
night so
we follow it through but we lose
thoroughly
and I'm driving around I see Tony stand
on the corner he'd run out of petrol
outside of church there was all confetti
out when he'd been a wedding and all
that kind of thing and I thought well if
it broke down anywhere it was
appropriate to break down there yeah
because leaving the body there to be
found in the morning and whatever
happens
little did we know
that a short way away lived for any
Foreman
did he get rid of the body
we dropped Ronnie Bender off
the commercial road yeah he went and saw
Charlie cray Charlie cray got in touch
with Freddie Foreman yeah asked him to
do something and the next thing you know
everybody's involved
Chris Chris so how much how much did you
get for that well I've got I've got life
with a recommendation for 15 years
and I didn't do that yeah sure so I
didn't help the police that's the truth
yeah yeah the police wanted me to help
your brother get for that 15 years
yeah recommended 15. and we did every
day of 15 years
what was the Turning Point why did you
leave the life of crime behind
well we left the license yeah what was
the Turning Point me as an IPP
yeah
they give me they gave me two and a half
years IPP
um
to explain that yeah is they want to
give you a sentence it's the most unjust
sense there is I know people who've done
the IPP they've come out mentally ill
Chris I'll come out [ __ ] mentally ill
yeah 10 years give me turn up and
everything
but my turning point was different
um I'll tell you what happened with me
right
oh yeah
We're not gonna wait
well it's broke
out of a wire
because it broke me
what is this that's my daughter
that's me
I couldn't grasp on The Craze I work
with people who would never inform on me
I've done things that are wrong
and and and and
I've done it with him and they finished
up doing a prison sentence and he never
dropped me in it you know the kind of
people I'm talking about yeah okay
so what happened
I stand in the dock and I'll get 15
years I've got a daughter that's only a
baby
a little baby
that little girl made me change
she was what I let down and I wanted to
be out there I wanted to do something
positive you know I couldn't change
nothing now I'm doing 15 years and I go
before the Royal courts of justice and
I've got Mrs Justice Lane telling me
yeah she turned around and said to me
look you you I I I can't let you have
any contact with your daughter at all
for the sentence you've got I said Mrs
Justice Lane you did not make me a
father a greater hand than yours made me
a father and you could never take that
right away from me and she knew if that
changes Chris yeah it changed me a great
deal and she turned around and said I'm
gonna allow you one letter and one
photograph a year and I thought what
good is that for me so my wife started
writing me letters but they were like
shopping lists a photograph wasn't
something I wanted I wanted something
more sort of Sparkle in her eye and all
that kind of thing my daughter
and I said if that's what you're going
to send me I don't want it you know if
you're finding a problem in right enemy
or a photograph don't do it she never
did it again
I'd walked out on her
and she came to get on a bus to come and
see me and she said no I don't know what
I'm going to get out is that changes is
that changing bloody change yeah not
after that nothing after that nothing
yeah nothing but what I've got in my
mind is anger I'm gonna get out of anger
I've got pain I've got rage
one day I'm sitting in a cell
and I'm marching up and down but a lot
as you're running red and hot for sure
cold as ice and eggs I want to screw it
or walk through that door so I can kill
him and I can justify being in bloody
prison alone from your kids like it you
understand what I mean I've lost
everything it's all smashed yeah yeah
yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna destroy myself it's
what I've got to do
I felt it it was I'm just doing that
amount of time
I picked a book up and it was a bible
really and I looked at it I thought yeah
that's going to get me somewhere and
throw it aside
but then I began to think I thought
people have climbed mountains
they're fought Wars they stood against
all adversity and they stood on that
book
really
and I made it
um
I thought I was gonna make it too I
don't know so I picked that book up
and I put it I put it
by my head thinking the good thoughts
were going to my head
some positive to stop them
that rage that violence I had in me
people want change
though yeah
they're like me a Broken Man
you understand what that's good and
they've got children
who they say they love yeah but how much
do they love them do they love them they
give up drugs
do they love them to give up crime I'm
involved with knife crime what about
youngsters around running around with
knives now
I'm telling you something they've broke
their family
they finish up they might stab somebody
it might feel good you're on top for a
minute
but it's only a minute
do you have any regrets no I'm not at
all
I lost all that yeah but regrets
as right at the very end do we all of
course we have a question right at the
very end but not at that time right
um who didn't give a toss for their
customers they were told if a Armed
robber comes in don't matter if there's
customers there drop down behind the
counter they can't shoot for a
bulletproof screen what about the
customers customers got to take their
chances